foreign
comes from Jerry in Florida Jerry writes
my wife and I are debt free besides our
mortgage and I'm having a tough time
combating a family member who happens to
work in wealth management oh geez
this family member believes that using
credit cards and paying them off is a
great tool to build credit this family
also believes that using a credit family
member also believes that using a credit
card is better than cash because of the
rewards different cards give you miles
cash back Etc
with this member working in finance they
are more informative than I am when it
comes to managing money but after
listening to you for so long I can't
wrap my head around what they're saying
as the best option to build wealth
what's the best way to have a discussion
with this family member that I can stop
feeling pressured
whoa
ah I love you and I don't agree with you
and we're not going to be able to be
around each other if you don't shut up
how's that
or or
hey man thank you so much
um I appreciate that I I'm just not into
using credit cards and I know there
there's I've heard there's some great
things but I'm just not into using them
but I appreciate it yeah that's it yeah
you don't get a vote yeah don't get a
vote he's just a doob he happens to be
in your family but he's a dupe yeah and
most people have dupes in their families
and you just I have family members that
vote the wrong way I'm not going to
discuss politics with them because they
don't know how to vote they're not good
at it and let's let's let's let's look
at um his family member
using credit cards and paying them off
is the way you build credit if you care
about credit then that's a thing and if
you think that credit is going to cause
you to build wealth which is an
interesting dichotomy because most
millionaires don't believe that correct
not little doob in the wealth management
business believes that but he's 26 and
has an MBA so he's correct I'm just
opting out of that system
if you want to build credit yeah but
building credit's not a method to build
wealth no it's a waste of yeah unless
you're wanting to build wealth for the
bank it's a good it's a fun way to run
around in a circle and make other people
Rich
um can you can you get rewards from
using credit cards yes I have chosen in
my house with my family to opt out of a
system because my flights are not free
the person who pays for my flights is a
single mom who can't make her payments
who somebody said if you use this little
plastic card it'll get you till next
week and she's buying my flights and I
refuse to let the people in the margins
pay for
crap my family's doing I'm not I'm
opting out of that system the number of
millionaires in the larger study of
millionaires ever done that said they
made their money on cash back rewards
and airline miles is precisely zero zero
none none of them no millionaire ever
said I became wealthy with airline miles
and it's just dumber and crud but it's
it's it's different I mean it's not
different it's people think they're
they're beating the system but also the
way those points are presented as though
the bank or the gas station is hooking
you up these flights are helping you out
because you're Bros now they're not
they're not your friend they're not your
friend but here you know the overall
answer how do you deal with the pressure
from a doob family member is simply this
those convinced against their will are
of the same opinion still my grandmother
used to say so you're not going to be
able to argue with him enough to where
he quits being a doob because he is a
professional dude I mean he's just a
duper okay and so you can't talk to him
you can't talk him out of being who he
is you can't present enough information
that he's going to change his mind
there's not going to be an argument
about it and so just that so once you
realize you're not going to be able to
change him
he's not gonna be able to change you
then the best thing we can do if we want
to remain on good terms let's not talk
about the subject correct because
I'm just going to get pissed off at you
and let's think of the word pressure
pressure comes from two sides there's
got to be a bottom to it and it's got to
be compressed
I I don't allow people to provide
pressure put pressure on me because I
don't feel like my back's up against the
wall I'm not going to engage in the
conversation I'm going to walk away from
you right yeah the first time I had this
I had a guy that was a car dealer that
was a Christian
and he called up and uh called up a
friend of mine that was we had a mutual
friend a pastor and the Pastor said hey
so-and-so wants to meet with you because
he believes you know his brothers in
Christ that you all have an honest
disagreement he wants to have a
discussion with you about it well he's a
car dealer and he sells car leases
and I said well yeah I'll be happy to
meet with him but the net result of the
conversation when we're done is he's
going to go back to the office and Lease
cars and I'm going to turn on a micro
turn on a microphone and say if you
lease cars you're stupid
and we both love Jesus
and but I'm not he's not I'm not going
to talk him into not leasing cars and
he's not going to present any
information as much as I know about the
subject that's going to make me suddenly
believe leasing cars is a good idea
but I did this was early in my career
out of an effort of spirituality I
thought well I'll sit down with my
brother and we'll try to talk that was a
complete waste of air
it's a complete waste of air because
there was nothing was going to change as
a result of the conversation and we did
manage to get out of it being kind and
nice to each other and agreeing that
we're not ever going to agree and that
you know he's you know but but he didn't
go back and go I'm going to quit leasing
cars you're a little duber of wealth
manager is not going to quit using his
credit card no matter what you say so
just quit having the conversation is the
point it's useless I have car I answer
questions for people that ask them not
for people who don't ask them that's
become a life-changing bit of wisdom for
me over the last few years I only answer
questions that I'm asked yeah and so my
friend the other day leased a car came
over to my house to show me his new car
it's a fabulous car by the way oh God
it's a great car
but he didn't come over there for me to
teach him about car leases he'd already
made his decision so I you know he
didn't say forgive me Father for I have
sinned he didn't do that he just brought
his stupid car over and I love his car
and I'm love him and and he's an idiot
for the way he bought it but the car is
amazing and I love him and that's great
and you know we've all got a friend
that's not smart and I got one too you
know and so but he's got a great car for
a little while while he rents it but you
know that's it and so you know but that
you just gotta decide what conversations
you're going to enter into and I'm not
going to sit and preach at that guy it
does no good he's got a car sitting
there well I think he's going to take it
back because Dave Ramsey doesn't like it
he's not going to take it back he didn't
ask my opinion
he just asked my opinion that I like the
color I do it's a beautiful car
there you go
and you might go buy it after he pays
for all the depreciation
yeah probably not that one but that's a
good car it was a fun conversation but
yeah I I
you know it's like my cousins are mine's
not but I have that there's a question
over there is my cousin's a whole life
agent and he sold me the whole life
policy you're not going to talk your
cousin into the idea that whole life is
sucks it does suck it's a horrible
product but you're not going to talk a
whole life agent into that fact because
he'd have to quit his job if he had
integrity and so that this is a big
conversation you're not going to talk
him out of it but you can just explain
to him I'm no longer owning the policy
because that's my territory I get to
make decisions inside that fence and I'm
not gonna you know I'm not gonna play
anymore well you know what we're not
going to talk about it anymore because
you're not going to talk him out of it
and he's not going to talk you into it
if you're smart right yeah it's walking
away walk away yeah walk away you can't
teach you to vote the right way we're
not going to talk about politics it's
just you know there's no reason to argue
you know Trump's crazy Biden can't
finish a sentence you know Trump Trump's
the problem he probably caused dividend
not to be able to finish the sentence
and so you know God they're just
all evil and they're oh the whole thing
well they're combined age is 156 there's
part of the problem but yeah oh my God
but you know the the on you know but you
you people that fall on one side or the
other there is you just caused about 114
wrecks in the United States of America
just well add it up if these two dubbers
run for president I mean we're gonna
have to have a it's going to be
sponsored by insure it's gonna be first
sponsored by what's the diaper the adult
diapers yeah oh God
nursing home commercials everywhere